i want to talk about some things that
are close to your heart um
bob you have a son who has autism
and you've devoted your life to um
raising money for autism
to me the scariest part of it is knowing
as you get older
if your kid's in bad shape i'm going to
leave the world my wife's going to leave
the world
yes who's going to take care of my child
it's such a complicated thing howard
because there are so many kids
like my son yes he definitely has
very high needs and you know he's
non-verbal for the most part and he's
had
various issues but
there are you know what's complicated is
that
there's a whole it's still autism covers
this enormous
spectrum you know is your goal with with
uh i'll i want to announce this charity
event i think people want to
watch it are you trying to find a cure
for autism
no are you just trying to what are you
trying to accomplish
something here's the thing and i will
say this like
night of too many stars my wife and i
started
like 18 years ago and the whole point of
it was to be the fundraiser that was not
about a cure
and i'm not going to tell you that when
my son was first born and at first
excuse me first diagnosed and we saw his
skills regressed that we weren't
very scared for him and uh and
you know our first thoughts were about a
cure that's where all the information
that we were getting at the time was
was about you know like there were no
autistic voices out there for the most
part
it's very different now with social
media and with people
just evolving and learning and and
feeling empowered to speak
but back then michelle and i just wanted
to help our son get through this and
learned how to communicate his needs
that was our biggest concern
and and we we had a lot of trouble
getting into any kind of school
at all because there was such a shortage
of it so that's what we focused on we
were like jesus if i can't
get into schools for my kid with my dog
puppet
right it's like imagine all these people
who don't have dog puppets
you make a good point i mean you're
you're a very successful writer
and and producer of things how expensive
is it
my plan is never to stop working because
i know that daniel is going to
need people helping him all the way
through his life and
you know he lives in a house with other
autistic individuals young
in their 20s and um and daniel got
coveted and
it was our biggest nightmare like oh my
god what if he has to
he's going to have to be quarantined
within his house and he's going to have
to be confined
in his room but all these people who
worked at the house like
raise their hands like i'll put on the
ppe and i'll spend hours with him wow
did he understand why he was being i
don't know what his level of
understanding is but does he does he
i think he understands you know this is
a something i always deal with
people like daniel you know a lot of
people
kind of um assume because
daniel's non-verbal and because daniel
seems to
not necessarily be responsive all the
time because he's reacting to
sensory issues constantly that they
assume that
they can talk about him like he's not
there that's something that
drives me nuts you know because i refuse
to make that assumption
i just know daniel is a whole person
he's not somebody who has some disorder
that's prohibiting him from whatever you
think
like that he's just incapable of
connecting with people that kind of
thing
these people are whole individuals
with feelings and needs and
it's very important to keep to remember
that
and and not treat them as anything less
than
you know full human beings and they're
entitled to the best opportunity
to have the best life that's possible
for them and that's worth
that's worth a ton of money
you